WHO'S DIVIDING AMERICA LATER IN
THE SHOW AND WE START WITH THE
ALL IMPORTANT MIDTERMS.
A MONTH AGO ABOUT WHAT WOULD BE
THE DECISIVE FACTORS IN THE
ELECTIONS.
AT THIS STAGE, IT IS NOT ABOUT
PERSUASION.
IT IS ABOUT SETTING THE AGENDA
AND TURNING OUT THE VOTE.
IT'S TOO LATE TO PERSUADE
PEOPLE, YOU'RE TOUGH ON CRIME IF
THEY THEY YOU'RE SOFT ON CRIME
AND TOO LATE TO PERSUADE THEM
AND YOUR POLICIES ARE REASONABLE
IF THEY THINK IT'S EXTREME
HAWAII YOU CAN DO IS INFLUENCE
THE AGENDA, WHAT IS FRONT OF
MIND FOR VOTERS MAKING THEIR
CHOICE.
>> WE SAW THE VOTERS IN THE
DEBATE THIS WEEK.
>> I BELIEVE ABORTION RIGHTS IS
A JUNE VERSUS FREQUENCY SAL
RIGHT.
>> HE HELPED HIM ON JANUARY 6 BY
SUPPORTING THE OVERTURNING OF AN
ELECTION.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE AN
ABORTION, I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
KEEP A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE
AVAILABLE TO THE WOMEN OF THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
>> WE LOSE EVERYTHING AND WE GOT
VERY CLOSE TO THAT ON JANUARY 6.
>> ABORTION ON JANUARY 6,
ABORTION ON JANUARY 6.
SCREEN THE DEMOCRATS ECHOED BY
THE MEDIA SERVICE AND ABORTION,
INSURRECTION, INSURRECTION,
ABORTION, INSUBORDINATION OR
WHATEVER AND SHUT UP AND IGNORE
THE COMPLETE MESS WE'VE
MADE-OVER THE COUNTRY AND HOW IS
THE STRATEGY GOING.
NOT SO GREAT, ISSUES VOTERS SAY
ARE TOP OF THEIR MINDS VOTING
THIS YEAR, INFLATION, CRIME, GAS
PRICES, ECONOMY, THE BORDER.
ABORTION IN A RECENT GALLOP POLL
IT'S AT 4%.
NICE JOB, DEMOCRATS.
NOW WE'RE TOLD THEY'RE
SCRAMBLING TO COBBLE TOGETHER
LAST MINUTE MESSAGES ON ECONOMY
AND THE HEALTHCARE AND SHUFFLING
MONEY LIKE PANICKY LOSERS AND
THE CASINO AND THE NEW YORK
TIMES IS REPORTING REALITY IS
SETTING IN AS DEMOCRATS ARE
FORCED TO PLAY DEFENSE IN DEEP
BLUE TERRITORY LIKE CALIFORNIA
AND RHODE ISLAND.
AND OF COURSE NEW YORK WHERE LEE
ZELDIN IS GIVING DEMOCRATS THE
HALLOWEEN FRIGHT OF THEIR LIVES.
NOW, I JUST WANT YOU TO SAVER
THIS IN ANOTHER NEW YORK TIMES
REPORT.
DEMOCRATS MOUNTING A FRENZIED
PUSH POURING MILLIONS INTO LAST
MINUTE ADS AND WHIRLWIND OF
CAMPAIGNS TO ENERGIZE THEIR
DEBATES AND GOING INTO EMERGENCY
DRIVE AND EMERGENCY ALL HANDS ON
DECK MEETING.
YEP, THEY'RE WORRIED AS JEN PSAK
ICON FIRMED.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE KIND OF WORRIED
ABOUT WHERE THIS IS GOING RIGHT
NOW AND FELT WORSE OTHER THE
LAST WEEK OR SO.
>> AND HONESTLY PERHAPS THE
SINGLE STRONGEST SIGNAL THEY
KNOW THEY'LL LOSE, THE ULTIMATE
SWAMP CREATURE, THE MAN WHO'LL
DO ANYTHING FOR A JOB THAT LETS
HIM FLY AROUND THE WORLD ON
PRIVATE JETS PAID FOR BY YOU,
YES, JOHN CAREY IS WIND SURFING
TOWARDS THE EXIT AND HE'S
PREPARING TO LEAVE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE "HE
DOESN'T RELISH BED WHERE WHOD
BEFORE A REPUBLICAN HOUSE AND
SENATE".
IT'S IMMEDIATE AND DEMOCRATS
DON'T NEED TO RETURN TO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO INCREASE AND
THIS WEEK WE'RE FLOGGING THE
ISSUES THAT HER PARTY BOSSES HAD
DUMPED.
>> WHY DON'T YOU HAVE A MEMO AND
TALK ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
RAISING YOUR HAND AND MORE ON
THE LINE AND THEY WENT TO SCHOOL
AND GOING TO SCHOOL.
>> IS IT BAD.
OBAMA WAS THE FATE OF THE LINE.
GOING DOWN THE LINE BUT ACTUALLY
IT'S NOT JUST ROB RYANER BUT
IT'S ALL OF THEM AND ON CNN AND
THIS IS HOW THEY TALK ALL THE
TIME.
THEY'RE GOING ON ABOUT THE DOWN
ON THE LINE AND E HE'S
GERRYMANDERING AND THAT'S
WHATEVER AND WIPE AWAY THE
REALITY AND IT'S A MESSAGE AND
GAS PRICES DOUBLING AND MORTGAGE
RATES ARE DOUBLING BECAUSE NOW
IT'S NOT THEIR INFLATION BUT
IT'S THEIR RESPONSE AND HIGH
INTEREST RATES AND AVERAGE
PAYMENT AND WITH 1,000 A MONTH
IN THE LAST YEAR COMING OUT WITH
HIS PATHETIC MEGA MAGA GIBBER
JACKER AND DEMOCRATS NOT GOING
TO GET THE BLAME AND HAVE JAMES
CLAIBORNE LANDING WITH BIDEN AND
ADMITTING THEIR POLICIES CAUSED
THE ECONOMIC CARNAGE AND KNEW IN
ADVANCE.
>> DOWN IN THE ECONOMY REALITY
OF CRIME.
>> PEOPLE ARE PUSHING IN FRONT
OF ONCOMING AND PEOPLE
COMMITTING ANY CRIMES.
>> HOW WOULD THEY COMMIT THEIR
CRIMES.
THESE DEMOCRATS AND THAT'S WHY
THESE DEBATES THE FEW THEY
AGREED TO HAVE AND POOR JOHN
FETTERMAN'S ATTACK.
>> I DO SUPPORT FRACKING AND --
AND THE ONLY THING I DO SUPPORT
FRACKING.
>> RIGHT THERE THE HUMILIATING
FLIP-FLOP ON FRACKING.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEIR ENERGY
POLICY, THEIR WAR ON AMERICAN
ENERGY DECLARED ON DAY ONE OF
THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY HAS BEEN A
COMPLETE DISASTER FOR ENERGY
SECURITY FOR INFLATION, FOR
JOBS, A DISASTER.
AND NOW THE DESPERATELY GOING
WITH BIDEN EGG BEGGING.
IT'S A DISASSER AND EVERY ISSUE,
THE ECONOMY AND SUPPLY CHAIN AND
BABY FORMULA FOR GOODNESS SAKE
AND THE PANDEMIC ENDING AND TRAM
HAS THE VACCINES AND BRAG ABOUT
THE BILLS THEY'VE PASSED AND
PASSING LEGISLATION ISN'T IN
ITSELF AN ACCOMPLISH WANT AND
IT'S WHAT THE LEGISLATION DOES.
THEIR LEGISLATION FUELED
INFLATION.
GOING FROM THE PABDEMOCRATIC
SHUT DOWN AND EXPLAIN THE OTHER
WEEK.
2.6 MILLION AND LEVEL WITH TRUMP
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING THIS IS
WHY THEY'RE MAKING A SLIGHTEST
DIFFERENCE AND THEY FAILED ON AN
EPIC SCALE.
>> I